allora il progetto di cui parliamo si
pone un tema la casa nel mondo nei
prossimi 30 anni serviranno le case per
circa tre miliardi di persone che hanno
una capacità di spesa di 300 dollari
circa un decimo del loro guadagno
annuale e è un tema importante come dare
la casa tre miliardi di persone che
possono spendere 300 dollari come fare
una casa per 300 dollari
noi come gruppo indipendente abbiamo
così provato a dare una nostra risposta
a fare una ricerca
usando un'intuizione che ci è arrivata
sia arrivata dalla natura la vespa
rosaia una vespa basaglia questo piccolo
insetto che si fa la casa usando la
terra l'acqua il sole per seccarla e la
mente questa mente ha un forte contenuto
perché adesso siamo nel periodo di
internet cioè la mente è connessa quindi
di sapere e globale quindi poter seguire
questo modo di vedere che proprio un
approccio prendi quello che trovi vicino
dagli forma grazie al sapere collettivo
questo è il modello di riferimento che
abbiamo voluto prendere è nato uasp il
simbolo è la mi aspetta che protegge il
mondo che porta la terra e ci siamo
inventati un nome un po prendendosi in
giro perché siamo veramente nati dal
basso world advanced sailing project
immaginatevi un gruppo di ragazzi è un
gruppo di artigiani che dicono adesso
troviamo un modo per risolvere il
problema della casa
nel mondo
era una specie di gioco fatto con tanto
impegno e consapevoli che però siamo
piccoli uno delle frasi che ci ha
seguito che ci ha dato che ci dà la
stella polare noi usiamo due o tre
riferimenti una questa piccoli sottili
pensieri prendono forma depositandosi se
provate a immaginare è la vespa rosaia
che deposita i suoi pensieri e fa una
casa però anche un significato più
profondo più filosofico la realtà il
risultato del pensiero di chi ci ha
preceduto il futuro sarà il risultato
del nostro pensiero è più saremo in
tanti a pensare in una certa direzione
più la realtà cambierà
e vero questo c'è chi dice fantasia
bisogna dire che la crisi fantasia
bisogna stare con i piedi per terra ma
noi no noi pensiamo che i pensili
prendono forma come si fa a dare forma
ai pensieri prima di tutto il pensiero
devono essere condivisibili devono
essere rappresentati
il primo passo è stato quindi immaginare
una macchina che potesse fare quello che
fa la vespa vasai e cioè prendere la
terra mescolarla con la paglia perché mi
hanno visto che funziona bene acqua e
con una sorta di robot depositare nella
forma di una casa
il robot doveva essere esportabile e
quindi sono tre assi verticali si chiama
cinematica parallela perché si può
chiudere a mo di ombrello e aprire
quindi si può portare rapidamente
ovunque è molto leggero muovendo solo la
testa l'energia necessaria per
depositare il materiale è poca quindi
può funzionare con la luce del sole di
più o meno 2 kg di movimento di questa
macchina
questa era l'idea che è stata messa a
fuoco dopo veramente tante analisi su
cinematiche diverse lo facciamo così lo
facciamo cosa no quindi ci vuole più
energia quindi è stata una ricerca reale
però il primo passo è stato questo qui
sono entrati il mio gioco i saperi di un
gruppo
ragazzi che sapevano di segnare tre di
noi da artigiani abbiamo detto da si
potrebbe fare così così funziona voi
rappresentate lo è stato rappresentato
il primo passo è stato questo
l'idea è questa la visione questa quella
casa bruttina che abbiamo visto prima
che il risultato di un materiale anche a
bruto fuori luogo potrebbe diventare una
casa bella se usassimo solo il materiale
più antico unito al sapere più moderno
anzi all è voluto mettere x sapere
perché il sapere può dare un risultato
elevato potenza lo vorrei dire ma come
si fa ad agire partendo dal basso con
piccoli sottili pensieri che prendono
forma non volevano fare questa bella
casa ma non si erano nei soldi nelle
conoscenze devo dire all'inizio sono
anche andato in banca a chiedere un
finanziamento
vi lascio immaginare qual è stata la
risposta del direttore come vi occupate
di economia quindi potete immaginare
però noi abbiamo col pensiero della
vespa lo sai che i pensieri prendono
forma quindi non è importante guardare
troppo avanti l'importante è fare adesso
qualcosa subito con quello che hai
quindi quello che hai e una bella
siringa del lidl che escludeva silicone
un progetto di una cinematica parallela
di un robot che si muoveva un po
raffazzonato l'abbiamo preso abbiamo
messo assieme abbiamo stampato la prima
casetta che vedete real centro piccola
ma era un piccolo pensiero che prendeva
forma
poi ci sono dei momenti poi che il tempo
passa e l'energia viene a mancare la
fede la fiducia e l'intesa questo per
fede nel proprio lavoro può cadere però
un'altra frase che ci ha molto aiutato e
questo ciò che avresti fatto
avendone la possibilità e ciò che hai
fatto hanno lo stesso valore di fronte a
dio cioè in assoluto la motivazione è
già un risultato c'è un gruppo di
persone lavora per fare un grande
progetto di grande respiro che ci
riescono
che importa quel gruppo di persone vive
bene e fa qualcosa di importante perché
è la motivazione il risultato poi
abbiamo cominciato a mettere in moto
così le conoscenze e le esperienze un po
anche da persone di chi aveva una certa
esperienza come facciamo ad
autofinanziarci l'idea è stata
produciamo dalla visione vi ricordate
che la cinematica parallela grande non
avevamo i soldi le conoscenze ma
facciamo una piccola facciamo la piccola
bella e facciamone un prodotto e
pubblicizziamo quel prodotto sulla base
del sogno vendendo il prodotto avremmo i
soldi per finanziare il sogno quindi è
una forma di economia circolare il sogno
finanzia e promuove il prodotto il
prodotto finanzia il sogno questo crea
un circolo che ci permette di andare
avanti senza la banca senza nessun soldi
progetto è partito con 7 mila euro
adesso siamo in 30 lavorare in questo
progetto in questo progetto sarà la
prima roba è sempre la stella polare io
amo dire che il navigatore non
raggiungerà mai la stella polare ma se
non ci fossero sempre be dove andare
quindi io penso che noi la stella polare
della casa e della terra il nostro
riferimento come facciamo a andare in
quella direzione abbiamo cominciato a
stampare terra dicevano cosa stampato in
terra da fare bene dobbiamo farli case
quindi stampiamo line piccolo è però è
nato un estrusore per porcellana che
attualmente un prodotto naturalmente ci
sono degli artigiani che per primi
cominciano produrre oggetti stampati 3d
con la stampante 3d dalla porcellana e
noi vendiamo molte stampanti 3d per
porcellane questo è il primo prodotto
direi di artigianato digitale in
porcellana di di un aceto balsamico di
alta qualità che viene venduto
all'interno della bottiglia stampata 3d
ma qui nasce un altro concetto il
concetto della meyer economy l'economia
dell'autoproduzione cos'è la micro
economy cioè se non fare qualcosa e
venderlo queste sedie sono un esempio
della nostra ricerca
dovevamo crescere dobbiamo andare a
stampa non a casa 15 o alla stampante
molto grande e le prime erano piccole
questa è una stampante che fa un metro
cubo circa e cominciamo stampare sedia
ed è una macchina che chiunque può
acquistare e può cominciare a stampare
sedie quindi è un artigiano noi
cominciamo anche a vendere serie quindi
è un'economia dell'autoproduzione è un
concetto che ci dà molta spinta in
avanti si apre tante visioni perché
stampa materiale tritato quindi può
stampare materiale tritato che costa
anche poco
questo materiale tritato può essere
anche ricavato da vecchio plastica che
la plastica un materiale stupendo in sé
orribile per come ha usato perché viene
preso e buttato è invece un materiale
prezioso perché ha delle qualità
incredibili può prendere qualsiasi forma
della qualità meccaniche incredibili ma
prenderlo buttano a riempirci di
plastica la stupidaggine prenderla
tritarla e dargli forma e creare
prodotti su misura questa è la stampa 3d
perché non dare forma a un prodotto vuol
dire che sono tutti i prodotti unici una
stampante 3d costa uguale a produrre un
prodotto su misura è un prodotto di
serie per cui non funzionerà mai nella
produzione di serie
ma funzionerà nella microproduzione ogni
singolo produttore farà un prodotto
apposta per chi collabora con lui per il
suo amico per il suo vicino di casa
quindi è maker economy con le stampanti
siamo cresciuti e adesso stiamo
stampando anche cose di scala
architettonica questa viene dalla
thailandia ed è una stampa scala
architettonica e quindi le cose stanno
prendendo forma ancora non siamo
riusciti a stampare la casa ma siamo
riusciti a vedere che i sogni prendono
forma perché questa stampante dopo tre
anni è riuscita a prender forma e
l'abbiamo vista è una stampante di 12
metri che può costruire una casa che ci
ha dato una visibilità molto forte ha
fatto girare quel messaggio come vi
abbiamo raccontato prima la stampa il
progetto la visione il prodotto tra
adesso il comune ma sono barra salato un
bel pezzo di terra
siamo molto sotto gli occhi di quindi
abbiamo anche molta visibilità e anche
molto molto spazio quindi molti ci
aiutano alcune aziende ci hanno dato i
materiali per pompare alla terra per
dire per esempio di napoli da bunker ci
ha dato una pompa perché costa decine di
migliaia di euro ma che pompa la terra
tutto questo materiale per fare la
stampante con tutto il sistema di
movimento di pompaggio delle terre sta
nella del container quella del container
quello che noi vogliamo fare adesso è
una maker economy starter kit c'è un
container che contiene tutta
l'evoluzione del nord
il progetto dove dentro quel con tenace
necessario per fare una casa le sedie i
tavoli l'arredamento i piatti dove
ognuno è un produttore delle sue idee e
ci immaginiamo qui nascerà una piccola
città autoprodotta che noi chiamiamo
ciambella che è una città fatta di
progettisti sognatori che vogliono fare
il mondo futuro che piace a loro